I don't want your marriage doomed and I
don't want your finances doomed if he's
truly concerned about the price of the
wedding get married at the courthouse
and do a party later after you got your
house like it doesn't have to be all
that you can't get of the house there's
no I mean when you go through a divorce
the judge tells you what you have to do
yeah when your girlfriend leaves and you
got the whole mortgage and her name's
still on it and you can't find her to
get the Deeds signed because she got
remarried somewhere or got married to
somebody else somewhere and now we're
trying to get rid of the house it's a
dadgum nightmare don't do that people
get yourself in a mess